little red riding hood let's start the
story a different way
it was dark inside the wolf
human beings are creative storytelling
beings
they make art because that's what human
beings do
as a writer your goal is to keep your
reader believing
in your story even though both of you
know it's fiction
when i wrote the handmaid's tale nothing
went into it
that had not happened in real life
somewhere at some time the reason i made
that rule is that i didn't want anybody
saying you certainly have an evil
imagination you made up all these bad
things
i didn't make them up
if you really do want to write and
you're struggling to get started
you're afraid of something remember it's
only you and the page
the waste paper basket is your friend it
was invented for you
by god
[Music]
people are always coming up with new
theories of the novel
but the main rule is hold my
attention
any form of human creativity is a
process of doing it and getting better
at it
to become a writer by writing there is
no other way
so do it do it more do it better fail
fail better somewhere out there there
are other readers for your book
i'm margaret atwood and this is my
master class
you